all right I think we're ready to start
anyone who wants to anyone else wants to
join us for the talk with Scott cook
founder of Intuit so I'll just start you
know for everyone here at Khan Academy
who doesn't know both Scott and Cigna
cook or you know some of the earliest
kind of believers in Khan Academy and
supporters and you know to a large
degree
you know Khan Academy wouldn't be where
it is right now without a lot of their
help and so you know I just feel like I
owe you guys but with that out of the
way
we're just fans we cheer from the stands
the players who win the game are in the
room very nice thank you the but the
point of having you here and we know
whenever we have people of your stature
come to the office we think it's just a
valuable learning experience to have a
conversation with you and then to see
what what what's going on in your in
your mind and and and the place I like
to start before we open it up to the
rest of the team is you know you see a
lot of folks who've done big things like
start into it and you know when I was a
kid I always wondered how does that
happen how do you go from being you know
having a normal job and one day you
start a company that company becomes a
really big company so tell us a little
bit about that story how did Intuit get
started well I think for you it was your
niece was it
my cousin cousin cousin yes for me it
was my wife very good she was struggling
with her math problem no she had to do
she does our joint checkbook and she was
complaining about doing it she was very
good at it she's diligent and
mathematical but it was a you know a
hassle because she had to pay the bills
and he had to rewrite into the check
register reconcile and she complained I
thought hah this was in 1982 when pcs
were just starting to explode I said
Weymouth this sounds like the kind of
problem everybody might have because
everyone's got to have a checkbook
everyone has to pay bills and PCs are
now going into homes and this is very
solvable on a computer this is the kind
of task that computers are very good at
and so though maybe I'll write this
software just for fun
but I hadn't programmed a decade so I
figured maybe I should get somebody who
actually knew what they were doing and
so I found a student at Stanford
Tom Perot and he I co-founded the
company and with the goal of building a
simple piece of software that allowed
people to eliminate the hassles of
managing their daily monthly finances
and how do you go from that because what
you see a lot of in Silicon Valley in
other places is you saw a need you were
able to build a prototype to do it but
then there's a big jump between that and
actually getting traction actually
people using it how did you make that
that leap yeah for for us that leap
between launching it and actually
getting a lot of users was not a leap it
was a chasm and it was a crevasse
software the time was sold in stores in
boxes and you took money and we try to
get VCS to invest two million dollars to
give us the marketing money to convince
stores to carry it and convince people
to buy it and no VC said yes they all
said no including VC firms run by
classmates shows you how unpopular Sai
dia was so that was a big problem the we
borrowed some money we got a little bit
of seed money from some relatives we
stumble along we spent that we ran out
of money we had to give back to rented
furniture and rented computers we
stopped paying salaries we it was pretty
ugly and why didn't you just I mean you
know it was stressful
yeah our marriages this broke up and and
I mean given that why didn't you just
cut you know cut your losses and I think
cutting losses would have been the
rational thing actually it did look so
hopeless but I felt I was kind of boxed
in because we borrowed this money from
some people we'd I'd taken my father's
retirement money most of it we had the
two relatives who invested equity it was
kind of angel money but I felt I had to
pay that back and he looked at the
amount of money I'd have to pay back
through honest
work if I had quit and the business and
so I felt trapped that I can't give up
because then I got to pay all the stuff
back so we just kept working we just
kept working at it and at some point how
are you living I mean how are you paying
your bills and forcing signe had a very
good job in fact in either this building
or in one of the adjacent ones she yeah
she worked in a software company
software publishing Corp that had a
bunch of these buildings so she and VP
marking so she had a very good job and
so it was her income that paid the bills
and then what so how long did this I
guess this this crevasse how long was
this period and what was the what was
the the moment where actually obviously
you were you saw the the light at the
end of the tunnel well and it's actually
even worse than one crevasse there were
two something we tried started to work
and then it crapped out and so that's
even worse when you get left down let's
see we launched the product with great
hope in October of 84 and it was the
time when I finally felt the thing was
doing well enough that I could buy
something that wasn't a necessity
something optional that could splurge on
which turned out to be a CD player when
I finally could afford a CD player was
in late 87 and if that still was but
that was and so this was a story I was
still you know it wasn't buy it wasn't
like a hockey stick at this point it was
still a know slow is dead and so the
question you ask let me answer directly
the question Haskell so what actually
did turn the business around it turns
out it was word of mouth because the way
we built the product was different than
others had nobody up to that point
software is an industrial product sold
to corporations you know the big
software success was visicalc which was
sold to people finance people in
corporations and the UI sucked you
couldn't figure it out without training
or reading a book but that's why
software was we were the first people to
do consumer testing usability tech we
didn't call it back but usability
testing so we brought housewives in from
the Junior League because at the time
there were all these women who didn't
work during the day
and they didn't use computers we put
them in front of computer so I gave them
our stuff and said okay use it to pay a
bill
and they'd fumble and goof and we look
at it oh [__] oh oh yeah now I see we go
back and redesign it and we try it again
and refine it and have people who didn't
know the product no manual try it by
hand so we had done more cycles of
usability refinement and nobody had ever
done that before
so our product was actually usable and
fast compared to thee and we're selling
to people in homes no no executives
telling them to use it they gotta want
it
and so people started using it from our
earlier and feeble marketing and then
they'd start telling their friends and
start telling your friends and they
started to be demand-pull and it was the
word of mouth that ultimately took off
and then it just is the rest is and we
started tripling every year we triple in
size and went into the most kind of
obvious adjacent spaces tax taxes and
well it was you know I've learned
something about surprise in fact the
first question we talked about today was
what's been surprising I told him about
our burglary situation when yes I laid
out yeah there's learning and surprises
so we had when we ran our first so we
launched Quicken and even before Turk
Hoffman was just you know failing and
bumbling along we did a little survey of
the few users we had and you ask all
these questions and one question made no
sense it was a we you know at the end of
the questions where we were asking about
how do they use it whether they like not
like etc at the end there was a
democratic set so you asked age location
income and we asked a question where are
you using the product home office or
both and half the people claimed to
using it in office now this is a home
product so we thought maybe there they
don't have a home computer I mean this
was 1984 1985 maybe they're taking their
their stuff to work and doing it there
so we ignored it every subsequent survey
the same answer half the people we're
using it in an office now we thought it
didn't make any sense finally it started
bugging me why are people answering this
question wrong
so I said well let's let's go ask those
people what they're doing instead of
ignoring it this was years later so we
went in actually Colson and asked him
interview them went to visit them see
what they were doing and by God they a
lot of them weren't doing their home
stuff they were running a business on
now we built this as a checkbook manager
not business accounting and the mindset
everyone had is at business accounting
talk to any who's took accounting who's
an accountant here any accountants okay
now it's very good now and what's the
system by which you keep books for a
business in accounting want this double
entry double entry accounting with
debits and credits journals and Ledger's
but any expert will tell you that is the
only way and we assume that so here we
found these businesses using a tool that
had none of that no debits no credits no
double entry of anything and what but
they're using a throw of it they are
running their business on it it's where
all the expenses in the income flows
they're it's their accounting system and
then we thought what why why are they
doing this unexpected thing and it now
it's obvious in hindsight but of those
of you who took accounting in school
raise your hand if you took accounting
at school okay how many of you liked
accounting in school yeah you and I were
both weird but the rest of you are
normal most people hate accounting and
the people who keep the books in a small
business tend to be the owner the owner
spouse an unlucky clerk or assistant
office manager nine times out of ten
they do not know accounting and they do
not want to learn to them general ledger
which is a feature of all counting
systems is a world war ii hero so they
that's why they were using art product
cuz we were in english and they didn't
have to learn anything where all the
others was a massive learning curve so i
finally said well what would happen if
we actually built a product for
businesses but made it on the same
promise of no debe snow credits no
journals no i just put it in plain
english you see an invoice you fill it
in you see a check you fill it in so we
worked for that on that launch that so
all came because of a surprise today
that business which is quickbooks is
until about ten times larger than the
quicken business so that's surprised
which we ignored
for years has created a business and if
you add all of our small business stuff
we've added payroll and payments in all
that it's about 15 times the size of the
quicken business so I didn't recognize
it at the time but there's a pattern
about when there are surprises big
upside or downside savor the surprise
what's really going what explains that
that's not what we expected stop and
savor it's too easy to keep going all
right well that's a learn multiple times
so that's the story on some of our
subsequent businesses so now I know when
you ask me questions that there's like a
underpinning philosophy they're not
random they may seem random very good
and and and now before I open it up you
know where do you see Intuit going I
mean it's a much larger company now you
know how do you as a the leader or the
manager how do you try to navigate that
and where do you see is the big
opportunities and the pitfalls
now the pitfalls are clear it is amazing
how success and scale make you dumb in
an organization it is just stunning the
degree to which the creative inspiring
innovation invention suddenly starts
disappearing as you grow you add layers
decision makers managers try to get
rigorous and do all the stuff that you
have to do to be both efficient and to
be reliable well you know people don't
want their I mean we did launch version
of QuickBooks where your data
disappeared yeah randomly after you all
your data disappeared yeah this is a
problem you don't really want to do this
don't try this at home kids so you got
to get rigorous and but something
happens to you know without continued
innovation where I've continued how do
we make the current thing better how do
we find the next problem to solve you
eventually get stale and die so how do
you be both rigorous and inventive and
most importantly how do you free the
your most inventive people who are often
quite new to the company could be quite
young likely our renegades
how do you free them to invent without
the board the organization boarding them
and so we're redoing how we work along
the lines of lean experimentation
the thing I've learned is if you allow
normal hierarchal decisions you have the
problem all the problems happen well
meaning middle managers it just slows
down but what if you tell the middle
managers your job isn't to make that
decision well let the experience
experiments make the decision middle
your goal is to put in systems allow
your teams and your brand-new employees
to be able to take their best idea to
solve your mission and run it as an
experiment fast and cheap the internet
now allows us to run these fast cheap
experiments so there's this whole wave
of change called the Lean Startup that
Eric Ries has founded I've not seen any
idea enter the common parlance of
business as fast as the Lean Startup his
concept of pivot went from novel to
trite in two years I've never seen it's
been absorbed at least as language so
fast but he wrote the book about
startups I believe there's two groups
who need the Lean Startup even more than
startups this concept of lean
experimentation
and those are large companies and
nonprofits will benefit even more than
startups so we're trying to operate as a
network of startups inside where people
can try their ideas and we've got
coaches teams systems we put people
through a two-day experience where
people just sign up and by the end of
the first day they have their idea up
and running in some sort of test to test
their leap of faith assumption all to
uncork that inventive power that is what
has created all great enterprises in
South and Ally so that's kind of and if
we do that right then I won't have to
pick a direction our people will invent
the directions far better than I can
yeah perhaps absolutely I mean on that
note I'd love to take questions and you
won't have questions I have a bunch more
anyone
we started the company with a bunch of
surveys waiting on I described one that
helped us get the surprise on that led
to QuickBooks but I have become a
skeptic on surveys so I actually don't
guide teams to run surveys I tell them
avoid the survey we found there's not a
high correlation particularly if you're
looking at inventing new ideas and new
businesses new products there's not much
of a correlation between what people say
they will do and what they actually do
what they say they will do they'll do
about half the time well so that means
it's a coin flip we've had we did a
product in India which we have which we
surveyed users and we're trying to
figure out how to monetize it so we
surveyed we expected 20% would pay for
it was we've been giving it away for
free we surveyed users and 40% said
they'd pay and then we actually did the
test and took existing users and added a
charge and 2% paid just there's another
example a team working in payroll
division had a new wave for a business
to start up payroll they mocked it up in
screens showed it to 20 payroll
customers
these are employers someone here runs a
system to write your paychecks so it'd
do that person zero of the twenty said
they'd use it zero amazingly they didn't
stop to thank God they didn't stop there
but because of our system of
experimentation they then got coached we
actually had Eric Ries in coaching that
say and he figured out a way what you
could run an experiment in 24 hours to
actually see what people would do not
what they say they would do they ran the
experiment and 58 percent of real
customers did it if they listened the
survey we never would have done this
thing because they could take it to a
test a test of just a slice of it they
then learned that customers would we
fleshed out built the rest of it and we
got the fastest customer growth in ten
years in that business so what I've
learned is trust behaviors
don't trust surveys measure and monitor
their behaviors and then right after
behavior you can ask somebody why did
you do that or why not and then you
might get something close to truth so
that and do it more as an in-depth
interview of the people who just did
something or in a test just didn't do
something and then you might learn
something useful from the interview but
I so we when we go out and talk to
customer in an interview and observe one
thing we'll do is go and watch customers
as I find it's much more much more
reliable to watch people in what they do
and you've got an opportunity you've got
people at home studying or whatever we
could go watch and see actual behaviors
don't say anything just watch you'll see
things they would never comment about
the I'm on the board of the Procter &
Gamble Company they make soap tide and
pampers and other things and in trying
to figure out how to improve tide they'd
run surveys and one of the minions
you've got many things you ask about one
of which was the box the packaging and
they asked is it easy and the answers in
the survey where yeah it's easy to open
what years later they did some in-home
observation and they followed some
homemakers around watching what they did
and they then did observe a few people
opening a brand new box of tide and they
thought it was easy if you kept a knife
or a screwdriver next year and and
because women have nails and they they
couldn't open those things so they were
hacking at it but he didn't never come
up in a survey but they could see it so
the one the most the thing I'd recommend
is to understand customers deeply go
ahead and watch them we call it follow
me home testing leads to follow
customers home from the store
not exactly we'd ask permission so we
could watch them start up
well let me answer that in two parts one
the story of how we got into payments
and then the crystal ball gazing there
was actually one guy an engineer after
African immigrant who looking at our
QuickBooks users said ah they really
could use payments and in fact what they
needs different and what everyone else
is selling so he got our product manager
work with him and a two of them cooked
up this scheme and inserted it into the
product and by God it took off because
they'd found a problem for businesses
who accept payments when there's no card
present because QuickBooks is typically
used in the back office around invoices
and some customers wanted to pay with a
credit card like over the phone but
there's no card present and the whole
payments industry had been routed around
that card being the key so they invented
different economics and different
approaching embedded in QuickBooks and
so now we have a payments business
that's four hundred million in revenue
sizable all because of they found a
problem nobody else had solved and
figured out how we could solve it now on
gazing the about the future I right now
you're seeing a hotbed of innovation
around payments and things are becoming
dramatically easier to send money person
person to send me for businesses or
businesses to set up and accept payments
it's a it's long band payments a kind of
monopolize urquhart alized business with
a few major payment utilities such as
Visa and MasterCard or one central bank
run system called the automatic Clearing
House and now you're this rampant
innovations happen around so it's so
much innovation in most of it I can't
tell you how it's going to turn out but
it's going to get a lot easier and
cheaper for everyone the place we're
focused on is still in the back-office
because everyone else tends to be
focused heavily on the point-of-sale
but the place that's still being ignored
is that business that sends bills or
invoices out
and for example in rent payments here
how many of you pay rent raise your hand
okay
how many of you pay that electronically
most of the hands went right there
especially small landlords are not set
up to accept electronic payments and
it's a royal pain for you and for them
they gotta hang around the mailbox
waiting for the money to come in because
if it doesn't they gotta bug you so a
small team how many people you me how
many people is that team when they
started two or three two or three folks
that we can we can fix that problem and
so they invented a system called spark
rent which allows the merchants to have
the merchants the landlord to sign up
and then the tenants it can pay
electronically really quickly the
landlord can be anywhere on vacation and
they know everything it sends reminders
out cheap you know it's had some hiccups
but it's now the most popular way that's
that small landlords can get paid
electronically and tenants can pay
electronically so that's the that's just
the beginning of the kind of innovation
from that what we want to do is develop
a way so that our system will know that
you pay your rent on time so when you
try to get that next department in San
Francisco and there's five people trying
to get that apartment you've got a track
record that you can say that I'm you
know you can trust me here's my spark
rent track record so we think we can
then take the data and make it useful to
both sides
you know I when we're at our best
yes we can pull that off but that's a
real bit we're far from perfect on that
in our payments group again we've had a
group that came at a much lower price
point we've in our tax group group was
working on right now you know you go to
TurboTax and you got to pay your taxes
on a on a computer but this group said
why don't we use the phone and why don't
we use the phone to snap pictures of
those tax documents so you don't have to
type it in well management thought this
idea wouldn't work and outside experts
said it wouldn't work but they kept at
it and they've built something called
snap tax that works it's an app on your
phone and you snap pictures of your w-2s
and it asks if your taxes are simple and
a lot of you guys are it answers asks
like nine more questions and you're done
nothing we have done in and it's at a
lower price point it's easier nothing
we've done in our company's history has
gotten as higher ratings from customers
it's five stars in the app stores and we
get reviews like you can't believe one
person wrote in that she was in the
recovery room after surgery doing her
taxes and so happy about it
another guy wrote in the review in the
app store that it was febris in bed with
his girlfriend and she's so stoked she
might even wear the gift he just gave it
so but again was a small team had the
freedom to experiment and invent
something which is just that the
mothership wasn't working on so at our
best we do that there's other times when
I wish we were better
this is the eternal priority-setting
question no matter what size herein
before we launched we had more features
we wanted to put in that we could fit in
after we launched and now as a four and
a half billion dollar company there's
much more stuff we want to get to and
that people want to get to them we can I
have two thoughts on that and they are
kind of opposing thoughts one is make it
fast and cheap to run experiments so you
can try more things if it's big and
expensive to try something then you've
got to be choosy if you can make it fast
and cheap to test the leap of faith
assumption on which a decision depends
then you can try a lot more things so
this Eric Ries is Lean Startup Khan we
were already running experimentation and
then I discovered Eric Ries on an online
video and said my god that's our idea he
explains it a lot better and he took it
a lot farther so I you know circulate
the Lean Startup and look at some of
these videos it's really it makes sense
so that increases your capacity to try
new things and to try new radical things
because if it's fast and cheap it can be
radical the other
the principle is that the actual
important things is a small subset of
all the things you're working on what's
truly important here's an example so I
run I learned this technique from
another CEO to run a thing called a town
hall meeting so we'll get a group of
important customers together let's say
accountants because we sell a lot of
things to accountants and we'll get a
group of 12 them together in a room and
I'll stand up to the white board and
I'll ask them two main questions what do
you love about dealing with intuit and
each person write down private silent
work write down a list what do you love
about working with intuit second
question what do you hate about working
with intuit what's wrong what do we
where would you piss you off what are we
just missing the boat
okay silently each person write your own
list okay then once they have those
lists I stand up in front say okay let's
read off list number one and everyone
read their list one and I'm up the
whiteboard and fill out the whiteboard
with all the great stuff and I said
thank you that's great that's awesome
now let's go to question two everyone
tell me the lousy stuff and I write all
those ideas down and people will have
real passion about the stuff that's
wrong that needs to be fixed needs to be
changed and you'll get 30 items up there
real passion from folks and then I'll
say okay let's forget list one
thank you for let's focus on the list
two I'm going to give each of you five
colored stickers go up to this white
board and put those colored stickers by
the things that you find most important
you can put all five on one you can put
one sticker on each of five you can
split them up what amazingly happens out
of the 30 or 35 items that will be on
the board most get no votes at all not
even from the person who was advocating
it the votes a uniformly are incredibly
lopsided now they're not collaborating
to each other not comparing notes
they're doing this as individual work
the votes there's one always every time
I've done this one big one and then
there'll be a second that gets half as
many votes and it may be a third that
gets half as many and then it's noise
and then what we do in the meeting is
say okay let's dive into number one
okay what's the problem what's the issue
when does it happen how does it happen
tell us more what's the root cause we'll
go now how do we go about fixing it and
I've been to number one so basically you
should work with most of your effort on
number one small effort on number two
and forget the rest
organizations can't do that
organizations will work on twelve Oh
Suzy wants to work on this and boy
that's a good idea from they can't that
customer was so passionate and we got so
you'll get 12 and you'll underwhelm the
important ones you'll spend much too
much time on the stuff that just isn't
so this is the best example I've ever
seen how customers actually are much
more focused on what's important then
companies are and it's one big one you
know I tell folks what's the one and a
half things you should be working on and
then run cheap experiments so you keep
the idea creation because you'll get
surprised out of the cheap experiments
that's your safety valve to get
surprised but so that's that that might
be helpful
let's do a little show of hands how many
people want to understand all the words
in the tax law raise your hand how many
people just want to get their taxes
filed and get their money yeah we're not
in the education business that's your
business
we have found at least when it comes to
finance most people are exactly like you
they just want to get it over and get
the work done if they occasionally want
to learn more we've got a lot of what we
call point of need help we just click
there's a little blue underline things
saying what is this or tell me more and
people can click and learn more when
they do that it's typically not because
they want to learn it's because they
want to make the decision right so even
when they're quote learning more it's
only to make the decision and then move
on so we know what you're doing is Noble
and really important and crucial to the
world but it's not why people tend to
buy or use our stuff
yeah so why did we acquire mint given
our passion for internal innovation keep
mine we acquired mint before we had
ramped up a lot of the experimentation
work okay so we were we're not as good
as we want now but we were much less
good then but also we're I'm very
eclectic we want innovation and
innovative teams for both sources so we
both acquire and we teach and coach our
internal and enable our internal
entrepreneurs so we do both we certainly
don't I think was build joy of son who
once said almost all the smart people in
the world don't work for your company so
we want to be where almost all the smart
people are which is you know we're only
one slice of the smart people and in
this case with mint we had an internal
effort to do quicken online and mint and
some other competitors were pursuing
similar things and mint just outrun the
whole field they produced a better
solution that had a different business
model and was just better than what we
were doing so we said you know why fight
a losing battle let's go get the top
team and the top approach since we
require them their business is tripled
or quadrupled in size their ideas have
infused much of the rest of into it that
was one thing we were hoping to have
their ideas change the direction of
other businesses we've had them run the
quicken business so we could take their
learning and we gave them the quicken
business to run so we really tried to
maximize the wisdom transfer and now
we're building a mint product for small
businesses so again they have such a
good thing for consumers plus we're
adding much more to the MIT data and
what MIT can do for you but we're also
saying why can we take that same magic
and solve problems for small businesses
as well so that's some of the story I'm
in
your premise is exactly right when you
do your finances with any system it
accumulates the data so we've got a very
large repository of data on people's
taxes investments pending business at a
transactional level the first thing to
recognize is in my view that's not our
data
it's our customers data they allow us to
be the stewards of their data only if we
earn that so we can only do things that
the customer wants and gives us
permission to do and if we break that
trust people will run from us and they
deserve to the next thing is mint with
another piece of the mint DNA we wanted
was they were making better use of the
data than anything we've done we've
largely done nothing with big data we've
used the data to solve your immediate
problem but we have not then the way
mint has said Oh based on the your data
we can see that you be much better off
if you did X or Y so that was another
piece that we wanted to do to cross
pollinate from the mint acquisition we
now have a data team with a new leader
we took one of our leaders who's very
talented and added this challenge to her
so there the data team was focused on
how they can help into it with data and
we said that's nice but what we really
want to is how do we help customers with
data how can we change their lives so we
re oriented the data team on the mission
that you described so that hopefully in
a year or two we'll have more ways that
we can help people here's just one
that's already in in action it turns out
most small businesses apply for a loan
at some point seventy percent of our
QuickBooks customers have applied for a
business loan and most small businesses
get turned down in a rather slow long
ugly process where they wind up giving a
lot of data information and paper to
some bank that ultimately turns them
down plus there's a lot of lenders who'd
like to lend the customers they don't
yet know we think we can make that
happen because of the rich data in
QuickBooks we can help figure out who is
a good lender for you and then make it
easy for you to apply with a push button
instead of filling out all this paper
and then have a lender be able to
rapidly improve and get higher
confidence that they're lending to good
people because we've got deeper data on
your business than anybody we can only
use it with your permission but this is
an area where businesses really want
someone to take advantage of their data
to give them a better loan at a better
rate so we've got a lending operation we
don't do the lending we work with
lenders and we're trying to pioneer this
lending marketplace using QuickBooks
data as the kind of unique asset to make
it happen so that's an example and we're
getting some number of lenders are
playing with it and ultimate goal is to
build a better credit score based on
richer data so that more deserving
businesses can get better loans so I'll
I'll just finish up you know obviously
you are known as one of the you know top
managers and not only your industry but
in Silicon Valley or more generally and
you know you've you've had you've known
Khan Academy since really the beginning
you know what thoughts do you have about
what we're doing where do you see the
opportunities where do you see the
pitfalls and and which kind of your
general thoughts and advice for us as a
team I I bet some of you are better
aware of the things to be afraid of I'm
not sure I'm close enough to to give you
a thoughtful assessment of that
but I think one thing that would I can't
say is an issue here but has been an
issue in other fast growth operation so
you grew from about five to six million
monthly actives to about ten million
over the last year a near doubling and
even you know you're expecting a future
like that your superstars celebrities in
the press there is the curse of success
where things are on a roll what everyone
wants to talk to you which somehow is a
drug that causes people in other
organizations to take their eye off the
ball to stop focusing on two things one
what really solves the customer problem
yeah a customers using things are great
we don't to worry about that but
companies can persist in doing things
that ultimately are second rate just
because the second rate stuff was better
than what was before and they don't find
out the breaker and we think of
overstock.com who then just got
surpassed and crushed by google robots
by eBay or think of Yahoo which gosh
they were the darlings huge the Internet
company and then Google just went to buy
them because they didn't they stopped
focusing okay what's the major problem
to solve and how can we innovate and
solve it much hugely better and Yahoo
always was a place people came to to go
somewhere else and their search was not
good so stick to the Knitting of what's
the funnel problem we're trying to solve
what do people really want us to solve
and how are we the best in the world of
that from what I see you're working on
that so with the dashboard in that and
the other curse of success and can be
the curse that Friendster had so for
in-store was the social network but for
Facebook and even before it's the music
one out of LA myspace and they were had
taken off as a social network kleiner
perkins major VC had invested they asked
me to go down and take a look
talk to the entrepreneur and that was
good but he talked about the end of the
talk about some technical problems and
douve in to learn more and he wasn't
gonna long with this technical founder
or technical guy at all and the system
was crashing it just couldn't keep up
with demand it was collapsing and
ultimately that killed Fenster one of
the things that mark will say about why
Facebook succeeded is he had seen the
collapse of Friendster because of
technical bums they just couldn't scale
with the volume and he and Dustin
Moskowitz would just did German that was
not going to stand in their way
so they limited growth early on and then
they chest piled the resources to make
sure they were up in reliable so those
are some of the things I've seen other
cases of companies running afoul I'm
seeing good stuff here I don't know
don't know don't suspect that's
happening here but those would be some
watch outs from the history of some
companies who like you have been
shooting upward
oh great no thank you that's let me just
cover one more thing which is the other
half of your questions yeah which is
about how do I see the future maybe I'm
not very good seeing the future but I
can see today and there's a something
you may have seen this as an article was
in Harvard magazine about a physics
teacher there a guy named Eric Mazur
anyones yep very familiar the article
was entitled something like the twilight
of the lecture so Eric Mazur was a well
respected teacher on the physics staff
there he'd been teaching physics for a
decade I believe the tests that he gave
showed the students learn subject matter
he's all happy then he heard about the
University of Arizona that had invented
kind of a capstone test that tested kind
of like the Common Core did people
really get this stuff could they kind of
apply it and and the results on
University of Arizona was after taking
the semester physics that the physics
students there just failed this can you
actually apply it in real situations so
he looked and so now it's interesting
that those are University of Arizona
students his Harvard students almost all
of his students virtually all got our
number one score one or two in their AP
Physics so he just as a lark took the
test and gave it to his heart
students after they had finished his
semester of physics and by God they
failed it he said it was monkey level if
you had guessed red monkeys guesting
randomly you would do as well as history
now Erik is an unusual professor at a
research institution because he actually
cared he he didn't say well screw that
and back to the research he actually
said we what does it say about me what
am I doing wrong as a as a teacher I'm
failing these students Hey
so he dove in and tried to figure out
what was happening he has evolved from
that once I when I guys passed me the
article and then we reached out to him
and we actually spent some time with him
learning and he basically found out that
students don't learn from lectures even
from highly rated professors I just
don't seem to learn from lectures and
these are Harvard students they don't
learn to I mean they learn to pass the
basic test but they don't learn to apply
in a deep way so he started trying
alternative ideas he tried a very
different he's basically flipped the
classroom and the students work on
problems and then he can figure out
through a system which students got it
and which didn't and then he have the
students who got that section explain it
to the students who didn't and he said
they're much better at it because the
student has just tried it didn't do it
and they're now they're hearing from
someone who just learned it who just is
walking in their shoes and he says he's
now now his students Ace this test I
think there's a revolution in learning
from something that was done to you
education was done to people lectures
are done to people too turning education
on its head learning on its head so
people now it's up to me it's now become
something you do and you learn at your
speed and you learn by doing yourself
not by being reliant on someone else to
pour learning into your head you learn
by using you learn by doing that's the
way real humans really learn fast you
guys are in the vanguard of leading that
globally with the internet with the raw
inventiveness of the dashboard the
on-demand the lectures to understand how
the students progress creating a
platform so that math
physics and other subjects can be taught
by learn by doing this will change
learning and lifelong learning this is
the this is the invention of printing by
Gutenberg applied to a field that
desperately needs it and more than that
this is the sum total of IQ points in
the world is fixed it's what genes have
delivered to us but how you turn those
IQ points into productive human
potential into skills to be able to
solve problems to be able to see
problems to be that is entirely a
function of people's learning and can be
dialed up or down dramatically by the
learning method compared when you've
been in some class which was boring
badly taught or the great research
professor didn't really know English and
you just your learning rate is so slow
your love of learning just goes into the
toilet and then compare that to a class
where you the teacher was fascinating
where you could move and learn and try
things and they worked and he got this
feeling of accomplishment it's night and
day
igniting the fire of learning in
billions of people is a force of power
far greater than the printing press and
I believe you guys are the world leader
in doing that well that gives us a
little bit of pressure but but it's
exciting at the same time and so I'll
just on behalf of the whole team I just
really thank you that was really a
special conversation thank you
you